let's go next to our caller from the
seven six zero area code caller from
seven six zero go ahead oh hi David yes
who's this Michael from California go
ahead Michael what's on your mind I was
just wondering if you think it would be
better for the electorate for the
general would be better if it was
proportional instead of making it
popular or would you prefer a
proportional in what way the Electoral
College purports to be a proportional
system where states that have a larger
population have more electoral votes
what do you mean specifically by
proportional like proportional
representation of course you know by the
boat like by popularity you know so do
you mean like a green party gets 5% of
the net of the popular vote they get
like 5% of the seats in the house type
of thing something like that something
close to that yeah
okay I just want to make sure I'm
addressing the the idea that you
actually are asking about if it's that I
think that there's a lot of I would find
a system like that very very interesting
the downside to it is that it can allow
totally extremist elements that might
exist sporadically in different states
like imagine that a white nationalist
uprising hard to imagine right imagine
that there was some kind of white
nationalist uprising where a white
nationalist party had candidates in a
lot of different states get three
percent of the vote all of a sudden if
we have proportional representation that
would mean that they might get 12 people
in the House of Representatives even
though they wouldn't have won any of
their individual races that that can be
pretty dangerous so you can sort of
solve that by having some kind of
minimum requirements and got a minimum
threshold that has to be mad there's a
few different ways I think it's an
interesting idea but there are
definitely risks to a system like that
no I agree you're right but I was just
thinking no you know if you know I would
be better than what we have right now
where the winner of the popular vote and
each say gets all of the electoral
college which you know thing's very
unfair yet not in every state but in in
most states that is the that is the way
it works yeah Michael thank you
appreciate the call very very
interesting topic which we've talked
about before actually that's coming
before during live calls